like to bring out director Josh Trank
producer Simon Kinberg as Reed Richards
miles teller as Sue Storm kate mara as
Johnny Storm Michael B Jordan has been
grim Jamie bells and as Victor Von Doom
Toby Kebbell I know it is a lot of
people welcome back
Toby's second time today what what do
you love oh you love Kate all right well
don't be creepy about it all right
welcome welcome welcome everyone okay
Fantastic Four Josh let's start with you
yes sir so why hi everybody hey this is
Josh hello this is Josh he directed this
movie I have not been to comic-con since
I was 15 really yeah I stopped coming
because it became too Hollywood so
ironically I'm like so now you're part
of the problem yeah but it's good it's
good it's nice it's if it hadn't become
this then we wouldn't get like you know
huge budget fantastic for movies
absolutely so why was it important for
you Josh to take on Fantastic Four um
I've always loved the Fantastic Four
ever since I was a kid I honestly I
never collected the comics because you
know in the weekend with my allowance
either went to Blockbuster Video or I
went to the comic store and I always
went to Blockbuster Video so my my love
for the characters usually came out of
the Marvel encyclopedias so I just knew
the characters really really well and I
watched the cartoons so I you know after
we made Chronicle I just I wanted to
tackle the same subject again but in a
more as a movie movie and not as a found
footage film and I just thought that the
Fantastic Four would be such a great
opportunity to as a new film to explore
a side of those characters that I'd
never seen before which is the more
tragic origin that kind of you can kind
of see in the the first year of the Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby Fantastic Four where
it's more of like a monster tale it's
more of a transformation yeah Simon what
what was your experience and involvement
well they actually Emma Watts who
President at Fox called me when we were
finishing Days of Future past and I was
in Montreal shoot in that movie and she
was like do you want to come work on
Fantastic Four and I also grew up
actually loving the fan for comics but I
sort of was a little burned out on on on
superhero movies and I felt like I
needed a break and she said just talk to
Josh and so we got on the phone and Josh
pitched me his vision of what the movie
would be a more grounded dramatic
emotional character driven story that
like you he's been saying and we said
all through photography like it was more
science than science fiction and that
just it really hooked me so I wanted to
do it because the way he wanted to do it
miles how do you how do you approach
Reed Richards well I you know I think
anytime you're playing a real person and
I've done it a few times but now I
consider Richards very much a you know a
real person that there's so much there's
so much history to that person and
there's so much there's just so much
material out there so you kind of want
to you know cipher through a little bit
Josh was sending me books like quantum
physics for dummies and dummies yeah
yeah he was send me all this material
but yeah I approach it very very
honestly and I I just loved the you know
the opportunity for it I it was not
something I kind of joked around a
couple years ago saying I guess I'll do
a superhero film at some point and then
Spiderman came and went and I thought
that was it but just to be a part of
this this cast specifically with the
Fantastic Four I just think it's really
interesting the people that we assembled
for it and Josh's vision it's cool man
is a very cool film it's not just people
blowing things up which is great you're
gonna sit in that theater and I think
you're really gonna be just drawing into
this world and the mood that we're kind
of playing with great Kate you are on
fire you could do anything you want and
so what made you go I'm gonna do
Fantastic Four I need to be Sue Storm
like I need I need to make this happen
that's very nice thank you
sure hmm I I've always wanted to be in a
superhero film and what I loved about
about this one specifically was the
family aspect of it I also loved when I
met with Josh for the first time really
not having known a lot about the
Fantastic Four and the origins of it all
I loved his take on it and and the idea
of an origins film really grounded and
and raw and and maybe darker than what
people are used to and so I was I was
attracted to that and being a part of a
film that's different than I think what
most people have seen and how did you
approach sue can you can you sort of
give it tonally what she's like in the
film yeah I mean I similar two miles I
thought um you know one of the main
things that we are trying to do is is
make these superheroes feel as relatable
as possible and you know in the film you
meet all of us before we have our powers
so you really get to know who sue is
before she has this ability and before
she really knows how to use it and and
so that was a challenge but I but I
again I really relied on I relied on the
scripts that Simon wrote and and all of
the research and everything that Josh
brought to the table and and all of his
ideas as well great Michael what what
was your favorite part about working on
the film just like living out a
childhood dream
you know being a big comic book fan you
know and being able to put on that suit
and like you know playing such an iconic
character make getting the chance to
work with these guys again you know I've
worked with miles before I've worked
with with Josh and built that
relationship and that chemistry
you know it was an amazing experience
and it was it was pretty cool I mean you
know you're all you're always gonna be
that guy like people are always gonna
look up to you they're always gonna this
character is part of you now and did
that enter in when you when you took the
job did you realize that you know that
was part of the responsibility no 100%
no definitely you know you got to
respect the history and the legacy of
the Fantastic Four being Marvel's first
family and we tried to stay true to that
as much as we could no we always we were
very thoughtful in the process of making
this film you know what the fans were
thinking what they wanted to see you
know the expectations and also being you
know something new modern version of you
know a family and it's uh it's pretty
cool I think you guys really gonna enjoy
excellent Thank You Jamie yeah what can
you tell us about Ben Grimm hi this is
Jamie Bell you will probably familiar
with him you look you look great it's my
first time here so be gentle Ben I mean
I think you know in this incarnation of
Ben he's an every kid could be any kid
in any town in America he's a bit of a
an outsider and his social structure he
has one friend which happens to be the
genius Reed Richards who constantly gets
him into trouble and he always gets him
out of it
and I think he's a bit directionless I
think when we meet him I think you're at
that age when you're kind of a finishing
high school and you don't know what the
rest of your life is gonna be what
you're gonna do you know and then I
think certain events in the film
especially that their transition that we
all go through and the newfound
abilities that we all have been very
much becomes the best version of a hero
which is one that just looks out for his
friends and just protect his friends
he's very much the muscle of the group
and I consider him the the heart of the
group as well excellent
and now for Toby what is what is Victor
like in this in this incarnation I play
Doctor Doom I know you all know Doctor
Doom but he's the best villain of all
time
any comic book ever so okay why why do
you why do you think he's our best
villain
I think he is cuz we all think he is I
mean he is he's just led by ego
he's Reed Richards might be a little bit
better than him possibly so I want to
destroy him I will and that's a promise
so yeah I mean it's just that it's
allowing your ego to run riot and be do
you know what do you think makes a
really good villain like what do you
think makes people when you think well
they're supposed to there's a
protagonist and the antagonist of course
you know cheer against the antagonist
but but we fall in love with villains so
like what what is it that you think
makes a really good villain I think it's
very relatable you know whenever you
lose your temper you there's a part of
you that thinks ah you know I should I
should go and apologize I should go and
say sorry I should do something to make
reparation toward what I did but the
best thing about being the villain is
you just find a twist so that you're
always right and it's a great way to
live I mean not in real life just as
Doctor Doom excellent and so Josh yes
what I understand we're gonna get to
delve a little like the origin story is
a little more in-depth than in previous
and previous version so can you get that
for say the way that I kind of thought
about this is it's it's an origin but it
almost works as a prequel to these
characters before they become the iconic
version of those characters but for
something to work as a an entire movie
on its own that can you know really be
about this this group of friends that
become a family and they're they're torn
apart and they're pushed to the brink
and how far they can be torn apart until
they you know come back together and
just sort of story about strength as a
family so yeah and our have you argue is
the movie completely done now at this
point where are you in the process
I think we're completely done yeah we're
I mean I've just out of the out of the
mix stage like literally a few hours ago
so we're really so you came right from
next to here where yeah we're
finishing in the next few days
you